[Music]
look we have our stuff we have a
dishwasher a stove a microwave I know
can you read yeah we're gonna need a
stencil for this boy oh my gosh look at
our phone
it's practically complete smells real
good let's go see the carpet carpet
carpet take the shoes this is so cool
our house looks so cool
what's that oh they they haven't they
haven't put the batteries in
Wow oh look at your closet dude it's
done achtung it's not done they're
missing this and they're missing and
they still you guys do a lot of
touch-ups
okay cockroach in here we do cricket
it's a cricket
our first inhabitants not uh-oh
you got squatters in the house
all might be finally put this thing Wow
look at our bedroom oh I love love love
how light the colors I was scared as
gonna be too dark yeah I remember I
remember thinking an hour I was like
might be kind of dark
make you feel no sad with you know it
looks great I'm in the tile - this is
gonna be no we have to peel this off and
it's gonna be a nice clear crystal clear
Mary let the tub and everything nice the
tiles cold
we picked the cold tile because remember
in the current place we got right now
the tile is like warm are you can step
on it barefoot really in the kitchen in
our area so our current kitchen no it's
the type of like material that they have
it's like more textured in the top or
something and it doesn't get cold you
excited dude rain be moving in in like
two weeks yeah cool gear with the hands
in the pocket did a tin rub off on you
he's like we surprised you look see
these closets are done with the handles
look at this neighborhood it's
practically done look at the look at the
little park area over there practically
done
because the day has finally arrived
this is the day that we do
which means that a couple days we will
be able to close which means hopefully
by this weekend we will begin the big
move and I am like uh finally so many
months of us waiting I think it's been
like a solid six months maybe even
longer
thank you
in a minute you think we're supposed to
close at Christmas yeah we were actually
oh my gosh you're right
yeah two months late and you doesn't
Bend with us throughout their school
journey here and there are sprinkles
here and there now we're coming to the
end the finale I'm so excited to finally
move into this new house because every
day that we've been spending
in our current place I'm like uh I just
want to get out of here already so today
is a Wednesday which you guys
know what Wednesday's mean to us it's JK
news prep day because we film every
Thursday so Wednesday's are already
stressful enough but then today we had
to add on the walkthrough before heading
over to do this walkthrough we had to go
to the bank to make the wire transfer
for the deposit of the home
we were just not making it happen today
the bank was so busy so we have to
figure that out later but we just got to
make it to this appointment now current
emotions in this car is stress stress
very stressful we're very excited as
well I'm like I want to be excited for
the house and clothes and all that stuff
but then I'm like thinking about JK news
as well and how much work there is left
feeling that it's just kind of like like
and then oh yeah we were we got a mover
scheduled for Saturday if we can't close
then
we'll have to cancel the move
like gonna rewrite the whole thing again
yeah so that's really the main stress
factor is the fact that we don't have a
110 thousand percent sure that things
are happening this weekend that we're
going to be moving so we have our
landlord on standby - because
this Sunday it's gonna be March first
we're trying to do our walkthrough with
the landlord's I kind of just heading
back to place on Sunday so everything's
like really really like tightly
scheduled and we're just like huh but we
also have to remind ourselves it's not a
big deal our landlord is really chill
he's like you know if you guys need
extra days don't worry it's just that we
are trying to squeeze it all before the
first because we don't want to pay
double rents that's the thing that we're
just trying to avoid but ultimately if
like worst case scenario it's okay we'll
reschedule the movers we will tell our
landlord we need an extra however many
days and we'll figure it out it's no big
deal and I keep trying to tell myself
that in my head as we're heading over
here because of all these other
stressful things that we're thinking
about for like at least like I'm like
trying to
and be like okay it's okay we can
breathe practice mindfulness just focus
on how our bodies are currently feeling
I'm like my heart's racing my body
temperature is pretty high I thought
today was gonna be cold so I ended up
wearing this sweater which was a bad
idea because it's really really hot and
we have the a/c on and I'm sweating I'm
just trying to paint to you guys your
current state and we're practically a
record still exciting times I are late
late ahead Isaac's in school in case
you're wondering where he is because it
is a weekday so he won't be
during this walkthrough he really wanted
to but I'm like nah sorry baby
seeing the latest like everything that's
been installed yeah he's seen the house
as it is
that we have carpet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me finish getting the wires done
yeah
keyboard yeah so while I was handling
the walkthrough PC ran over to the bank
really quick and then was able to get
the wire transfer to go through now
we're just waiting on one final thing
that the city needs to issue which
pretty much is a certificate that says
yeah
you live here then we will be able to
close so the goal
close my Friday which is in two days
yeah
[Music]
so cool because the guy that was helping
us do the walkthrough he was like
teaching us over to stuff and like how
to take care and like how to maintain a
lot of think you so cool he was like a
father figure he was like a dad yeah it
was really awesome and then it's kind of
cool cuz they both grew up in the same
city so we bonded over that and
graduated the high school the same year
I did which we were trying to figure out
if I knew them or not but I'm more of a
base person rather than the names person
so I'm like oh my gosh of your pictures
she's like I'm gonna bring you the
yearbook and sidon and stuff anyway we
bonded it was really cool we made sure
to get like every little like nook and
cranny that needed to be fixed
all right after I got that phone call
from Jess I forgot to switch off the
camera and continue to bring you guys
along the journey but what ended up
happening is we picked up Isaac yeah we
picked up food even coverage yeah we got
some food some Mexican food and and
mojado with burritos
well the other way around I don't want
hot oh yeah that's good but I don't know
if they call it Mac I love doing I think
we would probably like Ella
oh my groaning well at least they did it
for stuff that's our Ella's wet burrito
I don't think some Mexican delicious
more good Tex Tex Tex things I don't
think that's a real like Mexican tax
next thing would be queso burrito
covered with queso yeah but I'm saying
the fact that it's a wet burrito
well burritos to begin with are not
Mexican
yeah they're Mexican a little donkey
what it mean it does mean that that
looks really good you got this in the
beautiful
I did but I love how they put pineapple
in it bus doors main thing about that
mm-hmm
we found the cat's old collars that have
bells on it so that's the bells are your
cheering look my own I want to show them
see you got a little belt yeah why are
you so shy okay anyway let's eat guys
when provecho
when Robert movie and everybody one
porto-vecchio one for me one for vetrix
ma
[Music]
Hey
[Music]